avec martin mc colis analyse politique
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir martin mc colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france 5 ans
donc après ce référendum alors je sais
que la question est vaste mais je fais
confiance à votre esprit de synthèse
quel bilan peut-on en tirer bleus qui de
la jeune femme chiite d'hilla le climat
a dit viser le royer mieux car
l'angleterre locales ont voté pour le
départ femmes et des gosses et les
raffineurs rester au sein de l'union
jeudi soir le conseil demande d'imaginer
un référendum pour savoir si elle
souhaite rester au sam
enfin je crois que cette période
d'inquiétude extrême pour le
gouvernement à londres car en écosse on
semble voir indépendance le gouvernement
a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de vote
jusqu'aux prochaines élections en dinars
et catégorie plus de romain représentent
la majorité des populations pour la
première fois en irlande du nord de
l'irlande du nord souhaitait un
référendum sur l'addition ou la
réalisation avec la réplique à l'inde
alors cela serait possible il n'y a pas
de demande pour le moment mais c'est une
possibilité dans l'avenir proche
il pourrait y avoir une requête de
référendum sur la question du
rapprochement de l'irlande du nord et de
la république d'irlande et il pourrait y
avoir une nouvelle irlande une où ce qui
n'est plus le cadre de la ville
plusieurs décennies le point positif du
raid dit c'est que le gouvernement
britannique peut renforcer la recherche
sûre
excitation maxime jouets en peluche il
ya eu elle a une production très rapide
de vaccins plus de quarante mille
personnes ont été vaccinées c'est
considéré comme un grand avantage est
une étape positive
le point négatif c'est la perte de
confiance envers le gouvernement les
institutions gouvernementales
le système judiciaire et cetera car il
ya tant de divisions
les gens ne sont plus prêts à écouter le
point de vue d'autrui on a une culture
du groupe grandissante des politiques
culturelles etc
il ya beaucoup de conflits au sein de la
société vue concernant les points de vue
sur des personnes il ya il n'y a plus de
confiance très peu de confiance et c'est
une très mauvaise chose pour la
démocratie clairement problème de
confiance fragilité fébrilité au niveau
de l'ecosse et du dossier l'irlande du
nord bangui johnson néanmoins voit les
points positifs
il a dit que cette sortie se braque site
avait permis de réussir la campagne de
vaccination mais également la mise en
place de nouveaux accords commerciaux
donc sur le plan économique vous
partagez ce
optimisme du premier ministre si vous
m'écoutez monter cinq il ya cinq ans
j'avais été monté à quitter le vous
m'aviez demandé il ya cinq ans combien
de temps il faudrait pour que le royaume
uni se réhabitue à la vie sans l'union
européenne j'aurais dit cinq ans mais
cela va nécessiter encore cinq ans
regard de nombreux problèmes n'ont pas
encore été résolus
la relation par exemple avec l'union
européenne reste en suspens mais il ya
effectivement un traité de libre-échange
avec l'australie et le royaume uni
envisage de négocier avec les pays du
pacifique un nouveau traité de
libre-échange chose info du point de vue
commercial c'est une très bonne nouvelle
les cartes de maintenant les accords
avec d'autres états dans le monde entier
sans devoir passer par bruxelles
je me sens est considérée comme un point
très positif selon en citer un sondage
de l'institut savante à les britanniques
seraient désormais davantage enclins à
rester dans lieux 51% pour 49% contre
vous l'avait dit en début de cette
interview savons vraiment là la division
qui règne encore au royaume-uni ça veut
dire que ceux qui n'étaient pas
convaincus ne le sont toujours pas et
vice versa de 49 à 51 changer d'avis
qu est la cause de cela c'est le vote de
confiance envers le gouvernement avait
dit que la situation s'améliorait que
tout marcherait très bien après le
président et ça n'a pas été le cas
il y a beaucoup de conflits avec lui
mountain au sein du bundle il fallait
plus je souhaite insister sur le manque
de confiance gouvernement notamment de
la cofidis à changer de politique
encore et encore un index des écoles
jeudi que les premiers ministres se
contredit d'un jour sur l'autre comme
cela on va commandes de confiance envers
le gouvernement bulgare
s'il n'y avait pas eu de prix précis
qu'il y ait plus de confiance mais le
président a divisé le pays
le gouvernement doit trouver des
politiques et qu'ils pourront le fédérer
je vous donne deux quand le gars en
confiance le pays ne peut pas avancer
du point de vue économique et politique
merci beaucoup donc à faire